okay multi
Nick Jonas giving a rare glimpse of
daughter multi part of the Joe bro's
tribute to wife Priyanka Chopra on
Mother's Day this is a special thing in
the video posted to Instagram Nick and
pre take a stroll with their little one
who sounds excited to be out and about
with Mom and Dad
his father had been through because
everybody says it's life-changing to you
it is certainly life-changing she's uh
she's amazing
um brings me a lot of Joy she's actually
here it's not here right now but she's
in Tahoe and all is good Nick also
shares a snap of the mother-daughter
moment giving a close-up to Maltese
leopard print look for the outing
hey multi
as for Maltese mom Nick tells her in the
caption you are an incredible mother you
light up me in mm's world every day pre
has a special message of her own in the
comments thank you for making me a mama
I have a lot of faith in who my husband
is and I know I have a lot of faith in
the rock that he is for our family Nick
also Praises priyanka's mom adding this
pic to his Instagram story and writing
happy Mother's Day to my incredible
mother-in-law I'm blushing now this
comes a week after the actresses sit
down on the call her daddy podcast as
Priyanka tells it the Jonas Brother made
the first move after sliding into her
DMS literally like his message was
I've been told we should meet
how cocky
so sexy it was kind of an instant thing
knew once we locked in together that I
had a partner for Life yep but that said
Priyanka was only convinced he was worth
a day after watching this music video
[Applause]
that body deserves at least a day every
time he sings that song on stage for me
like I get weak and like I get weak in
the means I landed on that video and I
saw it I had to like open the window or
something he just came into my life at a
point where I had chosen me I was
happier I was healthier I was in a great
state of mind and he was like a
hurricane and I just kind of went with
it yeah and the moments for this
beautiful family just keep getting
sweeter it has changed everything for
the better of course okay multi
[Music]
good